A Utah polygamist family
the focus of a federal raid today.
This is the work of the Lord.
Utah's Kingston clan or The Order,
it's also called that, a
breakaway Mormon group.
The Order isn't really well-known
if you're not a part of it
or if you're not in law enforcement
or if you're not involved
in some type of a
I guess you could call it
the polygamist underworld.
One of the unique things
about the Kingston clan
compared to other polygamous groups
is that they do live right in
the middle of suburban Utah.
And the way they do this is by
not attracting any attention.
They had something like
a hundred businesses,
including a casino, a rifle manufacturer
and the biodiesel fuel plant
that Jacob Kingston set up.
Jacob Kingston has three
wives and 20 children.
He grew up poor in Utah,
had sort of a hardscrabble life
and was drawn to a very flashy
businessman from Los Angeles
who drove fast cars,
flew around in private jets
and took vacations on yachts.
Jacob Kingston was
seduced by that lifestyle
and that ultimately led to him
leading a much fuller life of crime.
My name is Jesse Hyde.
I'm a magazine writer based in Utah.
My name is David Voreacos.
I'm a legal reporter at Bloomberg News.
And we wrote The Polygamous Accused
of Scamming the U.S. Out of $500 Million.
Jacob Kingston
is part of the Davis
County Cooperative Society
also known as The Order. And in The Order,
the men are given numbers.
There's a hierarchy,
and they are expected to tie
their earnings into the church.
And the leaders of the church
have a very strong hand
in how they lead their
lives, the choices they make,
the wives they choose, the jobs they hold.
One of their early leaders
taught a principle that's very common
in Mormon fundamentalism
called "bleeding the beast."
Because polygamy is illegal in the U.S.,
there's a belief that
the federal government
really is the enemy.
And so with many of these groups,
there's nothing wrong
with figuring out ways
to quote unquote
"bleed the beast" or
"fleece the government."
The Kingstons over the
years have been investigated
for tax fraud,
child-welfare fraud.
One of the more common things
that former members told me they would do,
and they were encouraged
to do by their leaders,
is a mother would go in and
claim that she was a single mom
with seven kids to qualify
for different benefits
when in fact
she could have been the third
or fourth wife of a husband.
Over the past few years,
members of the Kingston family
who ran a different company
called Washakie Renewable Energy
have pleaded guilty to dozens
of charges including fraud,
money laundering and obstruction.
Jacob Kingston, from what I understand,
actually had the idea to build
this biodiesel production plant.
He recognized that there
was a huge opportunity.
The federal government was
really pushing renewable energy,
alternative fuels,
and there were big tax
credits you could get.
Prior to Jacob,
they had sort of focused on
businesses like pawn shops,
or commercial property
that's kind of shabbier.
Jacob was taking them into the big leagues
where he's standing courtside at halftime
at a Utah Jazz game, presenting
a big check to a charity.
So this really was a matter
of moving from the shadows
into the public arena.
You could almost think
of like "The Godfather,"
or any sort of mafia movie,
where over time, you want to
go into legitimate business.
You don't want to live
in the shadows anymore.
After Jacob Kingston got
his Ph.D. in engineering,
he then set up a plant in northern Utah
on his father's ranch.
What they did was produce biodiesel fuel,
which takes animal fat
or used cooking oil,
and through a chemical process,
converts it into a type of
fuel that works in trucks
and in manufacturing facilities.
The pure version of that
fuel is known as B100.
And what they then did
was apply for tax credits
that are administered
by both the Environmental
Protection Agency
and the Internal Revenue Service.
Those tax credits were a dollar a gallon
for the fuel that they produced
that was B100 or what's called B99,
a slightly diluted version.
And they also got a credit
for a renewable identification
number or RIN, R-I-N.
And that was a dollar a gallon as well.
And those are sort of the unique number
that can be traded between companies.
Washakie Renewable Energy,
a proud partner of the Tour of Utah,
is leading the intermountain west
to a future where our air
is clear, clean and healthy.
It did start as a legitimate business.
Kingston found that he could not compete
because of the limitations on his location
and the difficulties in
producing the material.
So he began to cut corners and cheat
the way other people in
the industry did as well.
In 2011, Washakie had
run into some troubles.
The biodiesel they were
creating called B99
was being rejected.
It wasn't pure enough.
And so he was looking
for someone to buy it.
And so he had sent a salesman out
to people who were
involved in this business
who might buy it.
And that's how he came across Lev Dermen,
and that was the beginning
of what initially was a
really profitable enterprise
for both of them.
Lev Dermen, who called himself The Lion,
was a man who, you could
say, a self-made immigrant
who created an oil and gas
empire in Southern California.
And in his adult life,
he was constantly under investigation.
And we talked to one of his associates
who said that the first time he met Lev,
he was struck by a guy who was
almost like wearing a costume
of a mobster.
He was wearing blue alligator
shoes, a blue alligator belt.
He had an office in Rodeo
Drive, and it was like,
"Hey, let's go down here for a meal.
My chauffeur will take us,
and it's like a block away."
But hey, if I can get into my Rolls-Royce
and take you a block and
the restaurant shut down
just for me,
that's going to create this appearance
that I am like an organized-crime boss.
And so he sort of
carried himself that way.
It's a question of how much of
that was just for appearance
and how much of that was real.
When they first met,
Lev Dermen flew his private jet to Utah
to meet Jacob Kingston and his wife Sally.
Dermen then flew them to
Seattle to meet a friend of his.
He wined them and dined them.
The Kingstons had never
been wined and dined before.
They'd never been on a private jet.
They went to a seafood store
and Lev Dermen bought the entire contents
of the seafood store to
bring home for the Kingstons.
Over time, Jacob Kingston was dazzled
by Lev Dermen's fast-living lifestyle.
They bought very expensive sports cars
like a $1.8 million
Bugatti for Lev Dermen.
They bought a waterfront house
in California for Lev Dermen.
They bought a $3 million house in Utah
for Jacob Kingston.
They took trips together.
He started dressing in a flashier way,
started wearing cologne.
He started cutting his hair differently.
It really started to change him.
He got a taste for the high
life, and he wanted that.
And in pursuing that
he was sort of breaking
an unspoken Order rule,
and that rule is to not draw attention.
If you start wearing flashy
suits and driving fancy cars
and having a luxury
suite at Utah Jazz games,
being public with your company,
sponsoring different things,
you're going to draw attention.
And so Jacob had a dilemma.
Do we keep operating the way
my uncles have run the family
by staying in the shadows?
Or do we go big?
Do we try to make a lot of money?
And for whatever reason
he chose the latter.
The EPA did not enforce
its standards stringently
and what fraudsters soon learned
is that if they were able
to produce documentation
that showed that they had
produced biodiesel fuel,
that the government
accepted that documentation
and they got their credits.
Eventually the government
got more sophisticated
at rooting out the fraudsters,
but there were several years,
particularly in the early
years, Jacob Kingston
and Lev Dermen perpetrating their fraud,
that the government
was not able to keep up
with the fraudsters.
So there was one particular fraud
where the Kingstons and Lev Dermen
used a supplier in Florida and Houston,
who shipped B99 on a barge and sent it
to the east coast of Panama,
and that generated phony paperwork.
And then they trucked it over
to the west coast of Panama
and they put it on a different boat
and shipped it up to Los Angeles
where Lev Dermen's company
said that he was shipping it to Utah
for processing at Kingston
biodiesel fuel plant,
the Washakie plant.
I talked to a guy who worked for Jacob
and he told me that they filled up
an entire rail car with water.
As long as they had the documents
to show that they were moving
what looked like biodiesel,
the inspections were so laxed
to basically non-existent,
but that was enough to fool the government
and cash in on these tax credits.
The largest and most dramatic example
where two checks combined
total more than $160 million,
that was ultimately their biggest payday.
There were other claims that they put in
that were disallowed as the government
eventually caught on fully to their fraud.
Jacob Kingston and his
family were arrested
as they boarded a plane in Salt Lake City
headed for Turkey.
Anything you'd like to say?
My client's not gonna have any...
A lot of the initial questions
that prosecutors were starting to ask
kind of tipped their hand
that this wasn't going to just be a case
about Washakie Renewable Energy.
This was going to be
a case about The Order
and all of their businesses.
And this would put everything
they had built at risk.
So in a way Jacob took this
big gamble for the family.
Let's go big time.
Let's step out of the shadows.
Let's make a lot of money.
And at the end, he paid
the ultimate price.
Yeah that's right,
the Kingston Clan has their fingers
in all kinds of businesses:
oil lubes, grocery stores,
hardware stores, private-investigator
firms, biodiesel.
And that biodiesel allegedly helped pay
for that $4 million mansion in Sandy
where one of those
warrants was served today.
The prosecutors were helped at trial
by the cooperation of five
people who had pleaded guilty
and testified under
cooperation agreements.
They included Jacob Kingston
and his younger brother, Isaiah.
Prosecutors showed at trial that they made
nearly $500 million and
that the claims accelerated
at the end of the fraud.
He then sent through a
very complex financial path
tens of millions of dollars to Lev Dermen.
Now to an eyewitness news investigation
in the strange alliance
between a suspected mobster
here in L.A. and a
polygamist clan in Utah.
Lev Dermen was convicted in March of 2020
after a six-week trial of
conspiracy money laundering
and fraud charges.
Dermen's lawyer complained
that the jurors panicked
and reached a quick decision
only because they were
scared about Covid-19
and they wanted to get out of there.
I've known my client for decades.
I'm confident that when he tells me
that he did nothing wrong
that he's telling the truth.
The second phase of Lev
Dermen's criminal trial
will be a forfeiture proceeding
that begins later this year,
in which the government is
trying to recover assets
that they say were the
product of money laundering.
Both Lev Dermen and Jacob Kingston
are in jail around Salt Lake City.
Neither has been sentenced.
Lev Dermen faces life in prison.
Jacob Kingston also faces
many years in prison,
but as a result of his cooperation
and the successful
conviction of Lev Dermen,
it's likely that he
would get far less time
than he ultimately could face
for the crimes he admitted
in pleading guilty.
The Kingston fraud was the
largest biodiesel fuel fraud
in U.S. history.
More than 30 cases, no
one had been accused
of the level of fraud
that they engaged in, that
they admitted engaging in.